[Music]
and this past weekend it was finally
confirmed in san diego the upcoming
ant-man and wasp quantomania will
officially kick off phase 5 of the mcu
director peyton reed reaffirmed this in
an interview with access where he held
out the prospect of profound changes to
the mcu through quantomania an official
poster by marvel artist andy park who
created illustrations for one of vision
and changji among others shows the three
protagonists of the movie scott lang aka
ant-man hope van dyne aka wasp and
jonathan magers as the new mcu villain
kang the conqueror in addition scott's
daughter cassie stars for the first time
in her own suit as superheroes stinger
who will soon all later follow in her
father's footsteps however thanos
successor kang will not be the only
villain in that man at the wasp
quantomania a still nameless villain
played by bill murray is also rumored as
is an appearance by modoc the latter has
his own animated stuff motion series on
disney plus which didn't go down too
well with fans and is not part of the
mcu there are also a lot of rumors
surrounding a return of corey stall as
darren cross aka yellow jacket in the
fight against ant-man he was allegedly
killed by the superhero but he might
very well continue to exist in the
quantum realm and be waiting for his
return indeed the biggest change that
mcu fans can expect in the new ant-man
besides kang and numerous other villains
is the introduction of this set quantum
realm this sub-atomic dimension will
enable time travel in the future and at
the same time it is a monthly setting in
itself that resembles a drug trip in
which space and time are suspended
either way it is a fascinating game
changer that much like the multiverse
and phase 4 will take on a significant
role in the next mcu films ant-man and
the wasp quantomania will hit theaters
on february 17 2023
this year's comic-con in san diego had
plenty to offer especially disney and
marvel provided lots of new information
about future movies and series the focus
was of course on the upcoming phase 5 of
the mcu which we'll start off with
ant-man and the wasp quantum mania after
the release on february 17 2023 things
will directly move on with a new series
called secret invasion this is where
samuel l jackson's fury and ben
mendelson's talos meet in terms of
content the first series of phase 5
picks up where captain marvel ended as
you might have guessed from the
post-credits scenes it takes place
almost 30 years after the first
encounter between fury captain marvel
and talos at a time when earth has
already been infiltrated by aliens the
so-called skrulls can hardly be
distinguished from normal humans and
this will be one of the central themes
of this series some familiar characters
will also be involved including kobe
smallers as shield agent maria hill don
chile as james rhodes and martin freeman
as cia agent ross new to the cast are
emilia clark kingsley benadir and many
more there's no exact release date for
disney plus yet but a spring 2023
release seems likely after that
guardians of the galaxy vol 3 will it
theaters on may 5th 2023 in summer of
2023 the series echo is also due for
release which will be a spin-off to
hawkeye and come out in the same time
period as the second season of loki echo
will focus on the death maya lopez who
was previously featured in the hawkeye
series along with the master archer
clint barton and managed to escape the
villain kingpin we can also look forward
to an appearance by charlie cox as
daredevil together they try to finally
defeat vincent d'onofrious kingpin loki
meanwhile will be one of the few marvel
series to be given a second season in
the year 2023 we can also look forward
to two movies that will be released in
summer and fall respectively one is the
capped marvel sequel the marvels which
will be released in cinemas from july
28th and blade which will be released on
november 3rd for the marvels we highly
suggest our original episode where you
can find out everything you need to know
about the mcu film meanwhile rumors are
still circulating about blade and very
little is known about the plot revolving
around actor mahashalali the period
between fall 2023 and spring 2024 is
then very much in line with series like
iron heart agatha kavanaugh chaos and
daredevil born again the latter stands
out with a very special characteristic
since daredevil will become the longest
mcu series to date with 18 episodes the
two films captain america new world
order and thunderbolts will then
conclude phase 5 of the mcu in may and
july 2024 respectively as far as phase
six of the mcu is concerned there are
three films that marvel announced at
comic-con avengers 5 avengers 6 and
fantastic four first up is fantastic
four in november 2024 followed by
avengers the kang dynasty in may 2025
shangshi director destin daniel kratt
will be in charge of directing as the
hollywood reporter revealed this week no
other details are known so far neither
who will be writing the script nor the
featured actors rumor has that doctor
strange and captain marvel are sure to
make appearances but so far those are
just rumors the title kang dynasty is at
least a reference to the comic series of
the same name from 2001 and 2002 where
everything revolves around the powerful
villain taking over the world a few more
months later things are to continue with
avengers secret wars on november 7th
2025 here too the title refers to a
massive event in the comics in which
many avengers and villains end up in the
so-called battle world and must fight
each other in the comic seriously action
takes place after the incursion of
different universes which is accompanied
by the almost complete destruction of
the multiverse doctor doom eventually
assumes control by assembling parts from
different universes into a new one and
founding the aforementioned battle world
there so things are going to heat up in
phase 6 which is clearly said to be
shorter than phase 5. we are definitely
excited and looking forward to more news
from the mcu what do you think about
this schedule for phase 5 and 6 of the
mcu do you think ken can follow in the
footsteps of fan favorite thanos as the
main bad guy and what could the new
avengers look like feel free to let us
know your thoughts in the comments
at the recent comic con we finally got
some first impressions of the upcoming
guardians of the galaxy vol 3. one of
the things shown was a first trailer
although it was only available to the
attending audience and is therefore not
available online in its present form it
is unlikely that the trailer will be
even shown to the public at all not even
in the future the reason for this is not
so much the secrecy but rather that many
visual effects have not yet been
finalized and thus the trailer is not of
the usual quality that's why we have to
rely on eyewitnesses reports say for
example that zoe saldana will be back as
gamora much as expected newcomer adam
warlock who's embodied by will poulter
was briefly seen as well likewise it has
been made clear that the third and final
installment of the series will at last
be devoted to rocket's origins and
genesis as confirmed by james gunn
himself in the trailer he could be
spotted as a cute little baby besides we
can hope for an appearance of the
sociopathic geneticist high evolutionary
who will be played by peacemaker actor
chugwudi iwuji a further addition to the
cast is maria bakalova who made a
convincing appearance in bora too she
will take on the voice of the telepathic
dog cosmo the security chief of nowhere
mantis actress bomb clementine also
shared first details about a character
accordingly mantis will still be quite
quirky and strange but at the same time
she'll become more confident and adapt
in combat last but not least nebula
played by karen killian is also set to
make a comeback after the death of her
father thanos she will be able to travel
through space much more freely and come
across as less grim the release of
guardians of the galaxy vol 3 is
scheduled for may 5th 2023 so we will
have to wait a little longer
the netflix blockbuster the gray man
started with mixed reviews on the
streaming platform last weekend thanks
to its strong celebrity cast including
ryan gosling and the armas and chris
evans the grey man did at least manage
decent streaming figures although the
action film falls behind other top class
movies such as red notice and don't look
up it is still the fifth most successful
netflix movie of all time as the russo
brothers who directed the film confirmed
to deadline this week the movie will get
at least two more follow-ups first a
sequel is being planned that will tie in
with the events of the first part second
we can also look forward to spin-off in
the sequel both the russo brothers and
actor ryan gosling will surely return
while the spin-off will highlight other
aspects of mark greene's novel getting
involved so far are deadpool authors
paul roernick and red rhys who will
write a spin of screenplay on top of
that joe russo announced that you can
look forward to an r-rating here have
you seen the grey man and if so what do
you guys think about the idea of
releasing two more movies feel free to
write us in the comments
all right that was our news vote this
week you haven't had enough yet then
check out our latest original for a
movie preview of captain marvel 2 the
marvels we've also prepared a great
compilation of all the new trailers
released at comic con ready for you to
watch on our channel we hope you enjoy
it
[Music]